[Music]
Texas son
many cities and states boast of having
the best barbecue you've heard the
claims from Kansas City Memphis and
North Carolina and of course add Texas
to that list where it seems like there's
a joint on every corner but few can
claim the rich Heritage of davila's
barbecue we asked our Texas
correspondent cbs's Janet shamlian to
give it a try
41. I got you I got you guys in the city
of Seguin there you are
davila's barbecue is destination dining
[Music]
and it's Destiny for Adrian Davila this
is where I'm in my my element the most
is
fire meat
he's a third generation Pit Master
decades after his grandfather started
the restaurant in an old schoolhouse
cooking in front the family living in
bed
whenever you're trying to live up to a
such a legend as my grandfather was in
the community as far as the barbecue
space like he was his Grandmaster
because he didn't leave the pits every
stick of wood every piece of meat every
sausage that was hung it's him his
decision only nobody else touched the
pits so that barbecue always came out
with his stamp on it and you felt that
responsibility absolutely my hairs are
standing up right now you still do I
still do Raul Davila was a butcher by
trade
indelible memories for Adrian I remember
him taking something that the time was
so Primal as a big cut of me and
breaking it down and making something
beautiful with it and when it came out
under the table and people enjoyed it
that was astonishing to me Adrian's dad
Edward took over in the mid 90s making
his own mark thank you sir
son to work in the family
the j-46 yeah okay
envisioning something better even though
it's all Adrian wanted but when again I
was able to see what it created and how
you created memories with food birthdays
celebrations anniversaries weddings you
create memories and I just that that
hooked me all right guys so did his
family's culinary history
this is your place all right yes this is
the ranch inspired by Vaquero's Mexican
cattle herders Davila took us to his
Ranch this is what we call a barbacoa
for a look at how they slow cooked meat
like this lamb in an underground pit
let's see the magic happened
you know how they have like the pool oh
my goodness a tradition he's keeping
alive today
look at that is that ready to eat when
it's falling apart like that there's
nothing but
you see the seeds of the Tomato the
onion and the jalapeno the carols would
celebrate like this Davila says
an outdoor Feast at a colorful table
takes a lot of love and passion to
create all this and that's what makes it
so satisfying
oh okay
influenced by the past but with an eye
to the Future Adrian now runs Davos
that means new items like the barbecue
grilled cheese sandwich chopped brisket
sauteed onions just a little butter on
there huh Texas toast and lots of cheese
get every little bit in there you have
to try this okay now one of the best
selling on the menu
that's unbelievable
can we sell more of these per day
then we do our regular barbecue
sandwiches really imagine that as if we
needed more Davila prepared for us just
about everything he sells their
Signature Sausage still hand tied every
day this is exactly the way my
grandfather made it not changing the
recipe ribs are a barbecue staple and
almost always pork but here they're lamb
go ahead and have a short bite okay
and then the vinegar of the pickle is
what you got to follow up with chains
are right into the sauce
dessert is big red cake let's have a big
red cake do you do this to go yeah yes
one of our biggest sellers right there
really oh yeah made with soda of the
same name a tribute to his grandparents
so it's big red oh my goodness my
siblings and I would go to Grandma and
Grandpa's house it was that big red cake
in the fridge it's our favorite thing
for Adrian Davila it's always been about
family from his wife Sarah his
inspiration and teammate to the men who
held title davila's Pit Master before
him
I was watching your dad watch you and
you couldn't see it but I saw the pride
in his eyes
he's so proud of you
that's what we all want right we're born
with this inherent trait to satisfy our
parents it's human everybody wants it
satisfy their parents right everybody
wants to make their parents proud
foreign
the steward of a proud family Legacy
davolos one of a kind
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Janet
shamlin in Seguin Texas
I love the fact that he wants to make
his Papa and Mama Proud he's done more
than that yeah he certainly has and he's
brought in some food for us here as well
I mean this is this looks incredible and
dig in but Janet had a field day I not
dish what did I just say she did it
right I want that grilled cheese and
look at this this is whiskey right
that's the best way pour it in here in a
little sweet tea because that's how I do
it cheers you're here Dallas right
davilas yeah insanely good